cinéma avec la sortie de black book un
film réalisé par le cinéaste néerlandais
paul verhoeven un retour aux sources
dans son pays ferait de l'occupation
hollande pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale un projet qu'il préparait
depuis 20 ans marie jo juin olivier
robert cet homme est connu pour
transformer les actrices on stars sharon
stone dans basic input lui l'hollandais
paul verhoeven a choisi sa compatriote
carice van houten pour retracer le
destin d'une jeune chanteuse juive
j'ai pour mission de séduire un officier
de la gestapo pour servir la reine et la
patrie pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale elle rejoignait la résistance
pour infiltrer au péril de sa vie
les services de renseignements allemands
face au thunder
c'est une composition de trois femmes de
trois histoires rassembler c'est pour ça
que je ne peux pas dire que c'est une
histoire vraie est ce que ce sont des
événements réels qui sont arrivés à ces
trois femmes et j'en ai fait un seul
garçon on se croirait on se croirait
dans mathari écrite est en vue pour
cette approche très réaliste de la
résistance hollandaise paul 0,20 à
consulter des centaines de documents
sont notamment concernant le black book
au coeur de cette intrigue un carnet
noir tenu par un avocat de la haye les
noms des traîtres et des collaborateurs
hollandais ils étaient consignés j'ai lu
le journal d'anne frank quand j'étais
petit des milliers de fois c'est pour ça
que j'ai tout dans ma tête ou dans mon
coeur
et puis c'est de l'histoire
j'ai été élevé avec ce passé là mon père
vivait dans le souvenir de cette guerre
et de l'occupation allemande à cette
héroïne survivants dans un monde hostile
violent antisémite a profondément ému
carice van houten déjà préoccupé par
l'état du monde
on laisse y est nous y sommes la seule
chose que je peux faire en tant
qu'actrice et que les gens se
souviennent grâce à ce film qu'il soit
démis et qu'ils en retiennent des leçons
le héros du film devait être un homme et
roven on a fait une femme anne hommage
au courage de tout les résistantes